la inflación sigue aumentando en la
eurozona y ya alcanza al 58 por ciento
en gran parte debido al aumento de los
precios de la energía según los datos
preliminares un alza que puede continuar
produciéndose debido a la invasión de
ucrania los precios se llevan muy
elevados desde hace semanas en la unión
europea pero la guerra no cráneo puede
hacer que aumenten aún más recordemos
rusia es un país exportador de gas y de
petróleo y por lo tanto la interrupción
de los puertos y de su actividad podría
provocar que aún aumentará más la
energía y por lo tanto la inflación las
sanciones contra rusia apenas se acaban
de aplicar de hecho no se descartan que
haya aún más por lo tanto en europa ya
se está preparando de lo que puede
ocurrir de hecho los ministros de
finanzas de la unión europea se reúnen
hoy de urgencia para abordar el aumento
de precios y también posibles futuros
planes de contingencia ante las
indudables consecuencias económicas que
tendrán estas sanciones de rusia también
para la unión europea